your insurance agency is back with p3
medical group to explain how they're
making access to healthcare easy and
convenient
here are the details first things first
can you tell us about your initiatives
and what are some of the ways you've
prepared uh people to assist them from
home heidi
telehealth is a new thing in all at
least my life and
it's really been a wonderful tool
appointments are available for a wide
range of health um
ailments including comprehensive visits
new patient visits
chronic disease management sports
injuries and more
and as a broker we've been advising
our clients to let them know we have
many ways to help them
so we developed a technology just by
going to our website
and you can just do a click on a button
says virtual appointment now
and that pushes you right into a
conversation and a virtual appointment
with uh with a broker
and what should people keep in mind
while they're scheduling the telehealth
and the virtual appointments
so that's a great point you're gonna
going to need a smartphone or a computer
with a camera with a video function
you'll receive an email and text message
with the link that will allow you to
directly connect to your provider
you will not have to download or install
anything on your device it's really
pretty simple
our medical assistants are really good
at walking the patients through all this
so they're
queued up and ready for the provider and
chris this next question is for you
what are some similar resources offered
by your insurance carrier partners
in this realm of accessing your health
team and remote assistance
so let's say you don't have an ipad or
you don't have an
iwatch or if that technology
we have plans now that will actually pay
for those services for them
because so they can do virtual visits
i even found plans that i have always a
zero co-pay
with these virtual visits so that they
can actually
have these connect immediately with
their physicians
and whatnot and it's just 24 hours a day
you guys make it so easy and convenient
for everybody and heidi
um what should people be prepared to
discuss when they when they actually
speak to the providers via telemedicine
it is really nice if they get prepared
with um you know a list maybe of their
medications
um but don't forget to test your
technology making sure the sound and
camera
are um you know ready to go so you can
discuss your health history current
prescriptions over-the-counter meds
and goals that you might have but it's
also helpful to have information handy
regarding any additional healthcare
providers or specialists that they're
seeing
chris do you have anything to add here
about your telemedicine via the broker
box
yes you need to know the medications the
dosage and the frequency because quite
honestly
if we're going to help you there's so
many plan changes
and everyone needs to control their
costs and they're worried about their
budgets
right any of you that need assistance
with a broker
when you're in a p3 clinic we actually
have ipads available to where you can
click on the button
or open the box and we'll take you right
into the virtual media to where you get
the assistance right there on the spot
things i wanted to mention that's
important is how do we access care for
urging care
sometimes it's after hours where you
can't get a hold of your
your doctor sometimes you're not sure
what to do
well there's a program called dispatch
help
which is mobile urgent care they're
awesome
yes
this information was brought to you by
alignment healthcare and your insurance
agency for more information call
702-425-5500 or visit
y i a lv.com and we'll be